okay so today we want to talk about
something I think that's very important
something that's not discussed enough
which is the imposter syndrome so as you
know the process syndrome is this
debilitating sense of inadequacy or
impostor ISM that some sometimes you
feel and it's a feeling that you know I
actually experienced when I was a
first-year I yell 30 years ago and I
have to tell you when I was a yearly in
those days there was no support and
there was actually the term imposters it
was even invented 30 years ago but it
you know that the feeling is the same
right this feeling of worthlessness the
feeling that you don't belong and the
and the feeling that you know y'all
missions basically made a mistake how
many of you feel that way that your
mission made a mistake and you you know
you really don't belong here okay so you
know it's a good number of people and
actually raise your hands and I think
one of the most important things to
combat in process and James actually
talked about it to actually know that
this is not a feeling that's originated
among among yourself and that there's a
group of people who are leaders in the
field that we could tell you ways to
combat this insidious feeling so I just
wanted to use our first speaker so the
way we're gonna do this is we're gonna
have two talks and then a panel
discussion I want a lot of participation
from you the panelists will give a
little especially the graduate student
panelist will give a little anecdote
about their dealings with imposter
syndrome cuz all three are graduate
students in the sciences and then I want
to open up to to you guys and ask
questions about your feelings in terms
of you know being undergrads at Yale in
the stem majors imposter syndrome is
also very prevalent among stem students
because there's not that many role
models out there right look look like
people who look like us for example and
I want to open up the floor to you guys
and ask questions so our first speaker
is dr. louise and as he is a clinical
psychologist and associate professor of
psychiatry at the Yoast University
School of Medicine he directs the
Hispanic clinic of the Connecticut
mental health center and has a lot of
clinical experience in providing
behavior health care
Latino community and it's contributed to
the development and implementation of
several projects that examine the key
factors necessary to create and
disseminate best practices in the
treatment of Latinos so dr. nedley's
okay so okay I was working today so
thank you for the introduction Dean Chen
and for inviting me here so we got about
25 minutes to give this talk craft so
they say clock there so I'll be looking
here and there you'll see me looking at
the clock so we don't run out of time in
this before I would be looking for
immigration since the doors open and
then I'll be looking for like which way
out so here's there okay so we'll talk a
little bit about what let me tell you
what okay so a couple of words about
some of my clinical psychologists some
of the things that I gonna share with
you are informed by my work but also
because I like the Indiana had this
experience I live with this syndrome for
about 10 years during which I was very
quiet in every meeting and it's funny
because when I ten years later spoke at
meetings about my opinions people are
like who is this you know whenever this
person has been sitting here all this
time so uh so hopefully some of the
things that we'll talk about may be of
help to someone and that's kind of like
the purpose so basically we'll go really
quickly as to what what I call it the
experience you know the impostor
experience who's vulnerable for days
what can this do to you a couple of
things about how to cope if you are
feeling it somewhere what are some of
the challenges and then what are the
opportunities so that's kind of like
what we're gonna aim to do in the time
that we have as a disclaimer and one of
those Latinos that are very
circumstantial and that's why I have to
look at the clock because every time I
say something I gotta tell you
story and then by the time I get to
where I need to be time passes so I'll
try to keep focus best I can
no no promises you know I just promise
the good effort so basically I don't if
you can read it but this says your fear
being posted publicly exposed as a fraud
it's a stress-related disorder called
impostor syndrome it's common among
people in high-profile authority
positions and of course in actual
phonies like you and when I was looking
at what to put in there one of the
things is that is this is very prevalent
kind of experience people have and
particularly in competitive situations
so it was at the the syndrome has been
going on for a long time we're talking
from like you know I could see people
building a fire for the first time and
one of them is thinking why am I here
but it was in 1978 with two
psychologists are actually wrote an
article and then kind of put a name to
it and they call it the impostor
syndrome and at the time the original
definition had to do with describing a
person's inability to internalize and
that's kind of like a psychodynamic
concept but what the gist of it is
really means is you don't believe that
what you are achieving is your own work
you'd believe this more of a fraud so so
at the time in the context in which this
was written that was the best way to
kind of explain it you know and the fear
of being exposed as a fraud so basically
the other concepts you might see is that
sometimes they say that people don't own
their accomplishments and I put it in
red because that's that that depends
you know they're variable so for
instance US mainstream culture is very
much about owning things and I own these
I achieve that the person comes from a
culture
that when things our own our own by a
group or in our share by a group the
person may feel reluctance to own an
accomplishment because they're just part
of the whole group they just don't
happen to be with the rest of a group at
that time so is so we take it you always
look at the context when you look at
this kind of our definitions but the
idea is the person may feel they don't
fit in and then they may feel that they
are a fraud despite being very
accomplished so we have kind of like the
experience and now it's not an
all-or-none for some people it could be
really accentuated for some people might
just be symptoms or pieces of the puzzle
so some people might feel like an
impostor at times some people feel more
intensely so it's not an all or no and
that's what will go like a case-by-case
so it's horrible to this so if you look
at some of the estimates and some
literature looks about 70% of a
population can experience or may
experience some of these things two out
of five successful people but more
relevant perhaps the person or the
individuals who are most vulnerable are
when you are different or you're a
minority within a group so one example
you join a hockey team and you are at a
hockey team and you come in from a
school that I've never had
representation of a hockey team in that
particular University and you happen to
be five inches too short so right right
there create some sort of a implicit
bias where you may feel that maybe I
shouldn't be here maybe I don't belong
here and the other people are just could
also notice that perhaps you know so you
have to kind of work twice as hard to
kind of prove that you belong there so
that's kind of like the just of it now
in that particular example you might
have coaches that are really really
supportive but there's a part of you
that
still not sure if you really physicists
look and that's that's when you get to
like the impostor part mmm so so far so
good
okay I asked because you know what
you're getting is a translation from
whatever I got here to English to
Spanish and to back to English and
that's what you get in and sometimes I
don't know okay so these are symptoms
that could occur from the imposter
but the biggest thing is gonna be you
can have and kind of like a negative
impact on your quality of life so while
you are at the park or you're watching
TV or you're having dinner with your
family or whatever is that you're doing
your part of you is constantly
preoccupied with this so your quality of
life suffers because you're not fully
present because you're always
preoccupied about this thing that you
need to do or this deadline and are they
gonna find out that I really don't
belong so so you're constantly battle so
you can promote thoughts and feelings of
inadequacy basically I don't know what
I'm doing with this okay so when I go to
the movies I usually sit back there so
when you know that's or buy the ticket
so so the idea that the danger of this
is that it can spill to other areas
because you get consumed about feeling
that you don't belong in a certain area
but then it could spill to other areas
as well and then now you feel an
imposter in areas that you should
perhaps you you're not there are not
competitive okay
so for instance one thing that happens
that is kind of like a new and safe is
this the person might get a compliment a
great job and then the person that
you're giving a compliment to is just
staring at you and then you're thinking
well how rude you know just telling a
great job and they're on you know them
they must the most the most be very
narcissistic they must be like and it's
not that is that the person doesn't
believe that they did a great job so
doing a great job and that creates
dissonance
and the person doesn't know how to
respond and that happens quite a bit so
people outside not knowing because
you're not talking about impostor
syndrome because most people don't want
to talk about it which is you know what
we support that you do but me so but it
leads to this kind of like awkward kind
of social interactions that isolate even
more and then in time the person finds
themselves a little meaner more more
isolated from the supports that they
could get so that's that part so it
basically so you are like okay so if
you're afraid of failing so you work
twice as hard but if you are succeeding
you're actually afraid of succeed for me
when I got when I got into I came from
Florida Tech psychology school very nice
school it was in a trailer we had two
classrooms a small classroom in a
trailer and the larger classroom in the
trailer and they moved to us from this
to that so I guess so you don't get
bored in the trailer so you know then we
come here so when I when I landed here
then I was very happy and I didn't last
too long because he was overcome by
feeling terrified what what have I done
Wow you know I need to ten years to kind
of resolve that so basically so it gets
you into this kind of like I don't know
what I'm doing again okay so so you're
kind of like stalk and then there's a
couple things so you start you start
over working but then if you get a
compliment for overworking your tribute
it of course I had to work three times
as hard as a social search or you
procrastinate and if you get the
compliment for procrastinating you also
don't believe that you were able to do
it so you are kind of like in a vine and
you're going around and around in
circles for you know until until somehow
you're able to break it so this can lead
to depression the anxiety so strange is
basically where's people out a lot of
people quit a lot of people and
if not because they didn't match up but
because they just were exhausted in
trying to work this true and but
ultimately even even if he doesn't get
one extreme all same people a lot of
like substance use particularly alcohol
because alcohol they used to relieve
anxiety so it starts little onions of
kind of worse but at best it's just your
quality of life because no one should go
through your years that you can have all
these contributions having to carry this
anchor which is not good for you or not
good for the people that are working
with you because they're not going to
benefit from the contributions that you
could have made so okay so how do we
cope and I know we're moving you know a
little fast but you know we're good
so some suggestions the first thing you
have talked about it that's it that's
you know don't do like like Finding Nemo
you know don't do like you know go only
a little fish and then you go into the
corner and then just say because that's
the natural thing to do if I don't want
to be found out I'm just gonna hide here
I'm gonna float here and I'm gonna let
past you gotta talk to someone now if
you can find someone in in the system I
don't know what I'm doing again so if
you can find someone in the system talk
to someone outside of a system if you
can talk to people in groups is better
because there's the sense of I'm not
doing I'm not doing this this on my own
so those are those are like those are
like big ones let's see we tend to look
at accomplishments in like black and
white holistic thing when actually an
accomplishments is a set of a small
accomplishment so what we want to do is
we want to break down what it is that
you accomplished see what happens is you
could have the you you could have
accomplished two things as a as a fluke
but not 20 not 30 but for you to do that
you have to like break it down because
we tend to look at the
whole thing and dismiss the little so we
we encouraged people to make like an
inventory of these are the things that
I've accomplished I'm not just necessary
in that area but in other areas as well
worker getting okay with compliments
because that dissonance you feel that
means that they're still that's still
there versus saying you know thank you
very much of that's a very nice thing to
say but you get a walk through wet the
only thing is that you want to diversify
because what happens when people have
this experience is that it tends to be
all-consuming
it's like I have someone as an illness
and then he becomes so consuming and
then you become the experience causes
input you become the imposter all day
long so what you do is you wanna you
wanna get you want to get your identity
diversified so if you if you like to
play basketball that's one identity if
you wanna if you're doing student okay
this is a one class or so that as as
many different things you do are the
different identities that you have
because then that way if you feel in
unsure about one thing is not gonna top
all the rest it's easier you compare
it's like compartmentalize I figure this
out this is like going on his own the
this is doing its own saying I'm doing
my own thing okay couple things
absolutes what do I mean by absolutes
okay absolute is absolutes really don't
exist but kind of exists in our heads
I'll never get out of this I will always
be this way always and never are things
that if you really look at them there
will be episodes when whatever you think
it didn't happen will happen so we try
to replace the absolutes with wish so
instead of saying I'll never get out of
this you could say I wish I can get out
of this because then you're expressing a
feeling that you have in it's a question
then the question is okay how do we get
out of this I don't we get that wish to
happen versus absolutes which tend to
occur quite a bit in the imposter
and then trying to see all this are they
are basically because we tend to
idealize so we're coming in to yell and
yell is this very perfect place and then
because there is a perfect place in our
heads and we are imperfect when they're
going to fit in so you set yourself up
you know so so try to see things for
what they are and the opportunities that
provide and what it is that you can
contribute
yeah it's a great thing in part because
of the contributions that you make and
that whole thing comes together versus
looking at I just as an external and
that's kind of like yeah that's about
that's about 25 minutes actually it
actually didn't I'm amazing it's rare so
and the challenges basically is how to
kind of educate so if you people kind of
get together and speak about this these
forums are great because it opens the
door for talking about it and it opens
the door for okay what kind of supports
can be can can be put in place so so
because you also want to create not just
this change in the individual but you
want to create a situation system that
that that that provides the support and
allows for people to be different and
let's see what it what we can contribute
together as opposed to people not
feeling that they fit in I'm feeling
completely isolated that's about what I
have for today and that's thank you very
much thank you very much so our next
speaker is dr. Meg Giry she is the
Israel's and professor physics and
astronomy at Yale and the director of yo
Center for astronomy and astrophysics so
meg has many many awards after pear
there are many awards are a few because
that we don't have time to talk about
our wars but she's a member of the
National Academy of Sciences and the
past president of the American
Astronomical Society but to me makes
most important contribution is her
amazing ability to promote and mentor
women scientists and she got so many
women physicists
into Yale and into the workplace and I
just think that's really amazing come on
now uh yes I can hear it okay yeah just
have to turn it into a show yes here's
the show whoops yeah there we go
hi so I do astrophysics I study
supermassive black holes I had to put
one astronomy slide on the background
you may not know sandy is like a major
major astronomer so I had to show him
some galaxies so um let me start by
telling you a little bit about me and
then I'll talk about well a couple
points really appreciate the the
information about imposter syndrome that
you've just heard and I want to talk a
little bit more about how that comes
about and what it's like to be an
outsider which is to say to be a member
of a group that doesn't look like the
dominant group and in stem the dominant
group is white men many of whom went to
great schools so if you come from some
other group if you're a woman if you're
a person of color remember of the LGBTQ
community
if you're a religious minority if you're
a military veteran there are many many
groups that don't look like the dominant
group in in stem at the moment in
science and technology engineering and
math so my parents were both they both
came from pretty poor families my
father's one of nine kids my mother was
raised by single mother they were the
first in their family to go to college
but by the time I was born they had kind
of had a middle-class life my father was
a professor of chemistry actually one of
many advantages I
in you know in becoming an academic we
attended public schools another
advantage was the schools were really
excellent also my parents believed in
travel and also they just I found this
out later they just sort of had a
scientific outlook so for example when
we were on family car trips we would
always have picnic lunches I guess to
save money and my mother would leave us
to wash the dishes while she went over
to some nearby stream and turned over
rocks looking for worms which we thought
was normal but it turns out not every
family does that so I had a lot of
advantages I had some disadvantages I
didn't go to a top college like y'all
are I went where my father was a
professor because it was free and money
was an issue and then the other
disadvantages I am a woman in physics
which believe me it's not an easy path
so some of you may resonate with a few
of the things I've said and many of you
you know have different characteristics
and I guess what I want to say is it's
not about who I am exactly it's about
you know whether you see yourself as
fitting in or not and ice definitely did
when I was younger I mean I was really
good in school I never felt like an
imposter when I was in elementary school
or high school I felt like a star to be
honest I I aced everything my biggest
problem was to figure out which one
thing I was going to focus on in college
but a lifetime of majoring in physics
and going on for a PhD in physics and so
on I acquired a pasta imposter syndrome
basically I got so much pushback any
time I claimed any kind of achievement
or you know tried to own it as you said
people would sort of say well you didn't
really do that or that's not really you
know your accomplishment so I think I
acquired a impostor syndrome so I think
I have some experience with it and
and maybe some useful advice so okay let
me try to say a few things so the first
thing I want to do is just talk about
the data and a lot of what I say will be
about gender in stem of course gender is
not binary but all the statistics are
binary separated in men and women so
that's a lot of the statistics I'll show
you this is a plot of the fraction of
PhDs in stem that go to women over a
period of whatever 1965 to 2015 forty
years so 1975 is about when I was in
college so you can see that back then
women were 10% or less of many
scientific fields the trend is good in
that it's upward but what is the right
number the right number is 50 percent
its parity and we are far from that in
many fields when it says all PhDs the
humanities and the Social Sciences have
have brought that number to a high
number but and biologists are doing
pretty well now but even in fields where
where the fraction of women is very high
for example biology more than half
roughly half the PhDs are going to women
now but fewer than 20% of the
professor's hired at top universities
are women so even even when the numbers
get big there's still problems this plot
is the fraction of stem degrees going to
women from underrepresented groups over
a slightly shorter time period and you
see doctorate is the orange line at the
bottom so the numbers are very low the
scale is different okay this is 20%
instead of 100% so the numbers are very
low and I'm sure many of you have heard
of this idea of intersectionality where
if you are disadvantaged along one axis
along more than one axis those
disadvantages sort of multi
why there's also differential attrition
as I've mentioned so I'm going to show
you a few graphs that look like this
this is bachelor's degrees from 1966 to
2004 in different fields black is the
total total numbers for all of stem the
high Purple Line there is biology the
blue line at the bottom is physics
physics and engineering are always
fighting for last place and within
engineering the biological biomedical
engineering is doing pretty well and
electrical engineering is doing pretty
poorly computer science is the one with
the big inversion anybody here
interested in computer science so it was
becoming a great field for women I guess
and then it inverted and actually if any
of you any of you in Hopper college so
Grace Hopper great pioneer in computer
science she had the advantage of being a
software person at a time when the boys
thought that hardware was the cool stuff
so they let the women do the software
that was like the housekeeping they
figured that was the housekeeping of
computer science and so they were you
know they were great pioneers and great
innovators and then as soon as the boys
figured out that software was cool the
women got pushed out anyway I'm gonna
match it to pH DS it's a different graph
but I've normalized them via power point
to be the same 50 from 0 to 50% is where
those lines are so look at this the
total number of bachelor's degrees 7
years later
56 percent going to women seven years
later 45% of the ph d--'s go to women so
I use seven years as a differential for
you know takes a little less than that
to get a PhD but you might have a gap
year or something so there's
differential attrition even if you take
all of the people who got their
bachelor's in a certain area fewer of
the fewer women fractionally will get
the PhD
here's math 47% undergraduates in
whatever that is 1996 and in 2003
it's 28% of the phd's pretty big
attrition
there's attrition in both you know both
men and women not every person who
majors in something is an undergraduate
decide Stata PhD but the point is that
the nutrition is greater for the
minority group chemistry 43% to 33%
physics 19% to 15% as I say fighting for
less place there with engineering and if
we just look at this maybe the thing I
want you to remember is that is creating
outsider groups there are outsider
groups and those groups have a harder
time excelling not excelling succeeding
in the field they have the same
opportunity to excel everyone does but
the recognition of that by people in the
field is not so easy let me say a word
about why you should care I think
probably a lot of this isn't news the
first is the excellence of science if
you wanted if you for some reason wanted
to restrict stem activities to the
population of white men you basically
are using you know it's first of all men
are only half the population and then
white men are like yet another fraction
so they're about a third of that right
now a third of the population in the
u.s. so if you want to have a talent
pool that's only one-third of the full
talent pool you're gonna have a worse
result it's also only fair that people
who want to do different professions
should be allowed to do so it's also a
great life we don't say this often
enough but it's incredibly fun to do
science
most people have jobs they don't love
and every scientist I know pretty much
has a job they absolutely love there's a
joke about a physicist which is a joke
in many dimensions but anyway why does
the physicists have a wife and a
mistress well first of all the subtext
is they're only male physicists you get
that it's because you can tell the wife
he's with the mistress he can tell them
as
he's with the wife and he can spend his
time in the lab anyway health of the
science profession again we need
everybody participating or the public
which is everybody wouldn't won't care
they're our workforce needs we need more
people in stem and I've just added this
one in the current climate or in the
current current events I think if we
don't have more women and other minority
groups fully engaged in public life we
can't stop
sexual harassment and discrimination and
racism and homophobia and so on because
the people who are there are not as
aware of those issues as people who you
know are victimized by those
discriminations okay so let's get to the
question why do women and other
underrepresented groups lag behind
parity when I was your age uh I didn't
even think about this first of all I
thought it was all equal haha I was your
age a long time ago we're talking like
40 years ago I thought it was over
you know equity existed it was just it
was just I guess there were no other
women who wanted to do physics which is
a ridiculous thought but anyway so why
and it took me many years to figure some
of this out so it has nothing to do with
ability interest or effort
I'm skipping all the references in the
interest of time but I'd be happy to
provide them for you
it is not family issues one of the first
thing people say to me as well women
there'd be more women in physics except
they want to have families and that's
why they're not in physics and I go oh
remember the graph I showed you how come
they're in biology
I guess physicists don't want don't want
to have I don't know anyway it's it's
such a not scientific argument let me
just say though so that you know this is
true women without children are not more
successful than women with children
number two there are women in many other
demanding fields medicines a good
but you have to be a resident you have
to be on call every fourth night or
whatever the the percentage of women
getting medical degrees is is 50% now
believe me being a physicist is easier
than that so Scandinavian countries
which have great parental leave and all
kinds of family benefits they have very
low numbers of women in physics and
fourth let me just say out loud
explicitly if you want to be have a
family and work
you should be an academic because it is
the most flexible career and you have a
resources to get help so it's nothing to
do with family okay we've established
that it's also not conscious
discrimination i I think that did exist
when I'm you know fifty years ago maybe
it's very rare now that you find people
you find them but but rare that you find
them saying I don't think women can do
science or they shouldn't do science but
um okay but it's unconscious and it's
also not men discriminating against
women reminding you that gender is not
binary we are all equally biased or
women are as likely to be biased against
women as men are so just a few caveats
so if it's not all these things what is
it and again I'm giving you the answer
without justifying it but there's a
lovely book by Virginia valiant called
why so slow the advancement of women she
uses the term schemas which are
basically stereotypes what do we expect
people to be like and we base that on
our experience so when we have only male
professors in science when we see only
men on the Supreme Court as was the case
when I was your age when we see only men
being elected to President to be
President of the United States etc etc
we developed the feeling that women
cannot do those things if everybody is
white in positions of leadership we have
unconscious biases that people of color
are not leaders so those are this is not
just speculation
expends and thousands of experienced any
of you social science majors are taking
social sciences I guess you have to be a
science major to be here Natural
Sciences anyway those experiments show
clearly that we have lower expectations
of outsider groups that we evaluate them
unfairly that people who are doing
equivalent the levels of work the
outsider group will be rated lower I'll
talk in a second about a couple of
experiments and that these disadvantages
accumulate so one of the first things I
want you to realize is that if you think
everything's equal now data experiment
shows that's not true
I it would be nice if it were but it is
not true ok let's talk very quickly
about experiments I don't have time to
go through all these let me just mention
the porter and Guice experiment this is
older but it's a classic but there are
modern versions people are shown people
it's like you you know college students
taking a psych class are shown
photographs of people sitting around a
table and they're asked to identify the
leader of the discussion you can you can
calibrate these experiments by having
photographs that are all men or all
women and but then they're shown so what
they do is they basically pick the
person at the head of the table and say
that person is leading the discussion
that's the that's the by far the the
greatest percentage of students picked
that person now when you show mixed
gender photos if there's a man at the
head of the table they pick him as the
leader but if a woman is seated at the
head of the table in the photograph half
the time they pick a random man
elsewhere around the table because women
are not seen as leaders there's another
good one again I don't have time to go
through all of these I'm just going to
I'm just giving you like a taste of it
but the Olman and Cohen experiment 2005
about that was an experiment with
resumes so resume experiments are
very common because they're
straightforward and easy to calibrate
and easy to test so in this particular
experiment people were told we are
trying to hire a police chief or in a
separate experiment nursing supervisor
and they were shown resumes only two of
which sorry back up before they were
shown resumes they were asked to tick
off qualities that were important for
someone to be an effective police chief
and that might include things like
physical fitness imposing physical size
a deep voice but there were other things
like having a family being a nurturing
person
so if you if you think about it sort of
stereotypical male qualities and
stereotypical female qualities then they
were shown the resumes and they were
asked to rank the resumes in terms of
who would be best for this position so
again you can do this in single gender
resumes right and what you find is that
people tick off about what you'd expect
for a police chief they want somebody
who's physically fit someone perhaps who
has previous experience as a police
officer and then they want but then they
want a man okay because in the resumes
if a man's name is on top of the resume
with those qualities they pick him and
say yes he would be the best police
chief but if there's no man with those
qualities but there's a woman with those
qualities they'll pick some other man
from the resumes because men should be
police chiefs not women now they're not
consciously thinking that and similarly
it works the same way for a nooner Singh
supervisor
that's a stereotypically female job and
they tend to give the job to a woman
whether or not she has the qualities
that they said Abba Nishio were
necessary for or desirable for a nursing
supervisor now the reason I bring this
experiment up is because it has a very
interesting twist they also ask people
before they saw the resumes are you
objective some people said yes
some people said no the people who said
yes were far more likely to switch
criteria and midstream and to pick the
gender they thought should be there
rather than the qualities the that they
thought should be there the people who
said they were not objective were more
likely to stick to the criteria they
initially identified so what that means
is if you are aware of your lack of
objectivity you can compensate for it
and be more fair but if you say you're
not objective watch out and many of my
colleagues have told me how objective
their how many have you been told I'm
color blind you've heard I'm color blind
or I'm gender blind how many of you have
heard that yeah not possible I think I'm
a maybe but kind of hard okay and if
they say that I think that means they're
unaware of their own biases okay I'm
gonna skip this this is just a quote
from the paper if you want to learn more
about these kind of studies Virginia
valuing has an annotated bibliography
there's no way you can copy down that
URL but you can just google Virginia
Valley and Hunter College annotated
bibliography you'll find it easily I'm
gonna skip there's a famous famous paper
done here at Yale by Curran master Kusum
I'll just say Jo Handelsman was behind
this Jo was a professor biology here
unfortunately has gone back to
Wisconsin's but we were privileged to
have her here for a few years
jo got she gives talks as I do about
women in STEM and she got sick of
scientists coming up to her and saying
you know this is all very interesting
but but all those experiments are done
on psychology majors and they're not
really scientists you know they're not
really training to be scientists we were
trained to be real scientists so we're
objective and we wouldn't we wouldn't be
biased like this so she ran the
experiment on scientists she sent
resumes to physicists biologists and
chemists and lo and behold the results
were exactly the same
which is to say professors of physics
biology and chemistry at top public and
private universities have a bias toward
men they're more likely to think men
should be given jobs in science that
they should be paid more and they're
more likely to mentor them so you can
look at that paper it's very interesting
it's another resume study okay yeah yeah
they were gonna pay him 30,000 a year
instead of 26 for the woman anyway if
you want to know about your own
objectivity and I highly recommend doing
this you go to implicit Harvard edu
mahzarin banaji was a professor here
when I first came to Yale and she has
done a lot of experiments on what
people's sort of internal biases are and
they judge them by reaction time in
pairing words and pictures on this
website and it's very very interesting I
mean everybody wants to pass this test
right everybody wants to be unbiased
if it helps mahzarin failed her own test
she's a woman of color
she's biased against people of color
according to her own test so if that
makes you feel better what was useful
about it for me was that although I
tried very very hard to not be biased I
could feel it I could full the test to
be honest I fooled it because I have
fast reaction times but I I knew I knew
that it was I was slower to pair the
word scientist with a picture of a
person of color that's a very hard thing
to confess but it is once you do it you
get a you get a sense of you know what
your upbringing has imprinted on you
okay so why does all this matter career
stages are filters you come as students
to school high school college you train
perhaps in a lab you get mentored you
get evaluated over and over again maybe
you get hired into a job perhaps as a
professor there are issues of
tension and promotion at every decision
point this disadvantage is working
against the outsider groups and in favor
of the in-group so so we are not doing a
good job of having a meritocracy all
evaluations used in the academic world
the criteria we use to hire and promote
people and to give them tenure every
single one of these has been shown to be
biased by gender by experiments women
are cited less they're less likely to be
published they're less likely to be
nominated for prizes if they are
nominated they're equally likely to win
but if they but there must less likely
to be nominated etc our teaching
evaluations are are more likely to be
negative etc okay this is a downer right
a little bit of a downer so I think of
this talk as vaccinations I am
vaccinating all of you the idea is that
you probably if you are in an outsider
group you probably will encounter
obstacles that your some of your peers
will not however there are many rewards
to the stem career it's well worth doing
and it's certainly doable I think
knowing that it's not level helps a lot
when I was younger and everyone was
telling me not only were they not
telling me I would see obstacles they
were telling me that I would see every
advantage because I was a member of a
minority group as a woman in physics oh
they said you probably got into graduate
school because you're a woman you'll
probably be hired and I won't because
you're a woman
etc etc how many of you been told you
have an advantage for being in whatever
group if anyone says that you asked them
for the data because as far as I know
those data don't exist
it's the other way around every single
data point we have says it's the other
way around so yes there may be
affirmative action programs but at best
they are compensating for the
disadvantage
that you already have I'm gonna say a
few words about how you can compensate
yep bike you should finish up so let me
skip the rest of this let me just say
the playing field is not level if you
take away only one message from this
talk that's probably a useful one and
the data the data tell us this it's not
my opinion but you can the tilt can be
leveled if you're conscious about it and
and if others are conscious about it so
I'm gonna give you just a few quick tips
these are not the only ones they are
things that are helpful and then maybe
I'll end with my list of advice
okay so affirmation is the thing that I
first heard about in the context of
women in the Obama White House so there
were a lot of type-a people in the Obama
White House and apparently women
couldn't get a word in edgewise and
weren't being listened to and many of
them had the experience of coming up
with an idea it'd go nowhere nobody pays
any attention it drops into the ether
and then some guy makes the same
suggestion a few minutes later and
everyone goes oh a great idea how many
have had that experience okay I've had
it many times so they decided to start
doing this thing they called affirmation
which is when a woman would make a
suggestion the other women were primed
to say oh I like what you know what
Hillary just said or what whoever just
said these were powerful women these
were women who are at the top of their
game and very successful you have to be
extremely successful to be in the White
House cabinet well okay
so so it wasn't like they were weak in
any way or unable it's just they weren't
being heard you can't blame the speaker
every time the speaker is not hurt so
they affirmed each other and that made
it much more likely that there they were
listened to other ways to do that are to
introduce speakers with validating their
credentials Thank You sandy for doing
that
for both of us etc there's a great
cartoon from The New Yorker from years
ago that's an excellent suggestion
missed Riggs perhaps one of the men here
would like to make it another thing is
to just get your head just get your head
realized a few things so how many of you
have heard that women lack math ability
really not more of you come on
I mean Barbie used to say this Barbie
used to say math is hard so there's a
thing called stereotype threat have any
of you heard of stereotype threat a few
of you okay so the idea is that people
perform below their ability because of
the stereotype that their group performs
badly so for example women are supposed
to be bad at math so even women who are
very good at math and will underperform
because of the stereotype that they're
bad at math and this is worse if you
excite the stereotype so here's an
example I read about this in the early
1990s like 25 years ago it was an
experiment done at UConn actually and
was in the Boston Globe and it blew my
mind so the idea was a class was given a
test and they were told this is a really
hard math test probably most of you
won't do very well okay that's exciting
a stereotype that is except you know
you're being like pressure it's it's
creating it's applying stress then what
happens men score twenty five out of a
hundred on this test women score 10 out
of 100 call the New York Times front
story page story that women are not as
good at math as men especially at the
extreme high performance end so Larry
Summers right this is the Larry Summers
statement but what's interesting is this
Claude Steele started this field
he's now I think the Provost at Stanford
or something he and gave the same test
to a different class and this experiment
was repeated many times and typed on
this test was this test is designed to
be gender neutral that's the only
difference in the experimental condition
okay so women now scored twice they
double their score
the only difference is that sentence at
the top of the test men score worse
so now women and men have the same math
performance and the only difference is
what they were told about expectations
about how they would perform and this by
the way has been shown to also be a
relevant factor for minority students
okay let me move on quickly I don't have
time to go through this one just about
yeah what this is about is how you
mentor people depends on who they are
not who you are should depend on who
they are some people need a kick in the
butt and need to be criticized my dad
was like that he needed to you know when
he failed at something he sort of came
back and said oh I'll just I'll just try
harder when I fail at something I go in
my room and cry and then try to figure
out why I shouldn't quit the next day so
I need a different kind of mentoring
than he did he needed someone saying
grant I don't think you're gonna make it
and then he'd come back and say yes I am
you know and I need someone to say
you're great could they say it more
often that would be really good you know
you're really great that's what I need
anyway perfect okay so um here's um
here's some ideas about leveling the
playing field
we started with equal opportunity in
this country that is a discussion of
let's just let everybody try and the
people who are good at it will succeed
and the rest of you won't so if you have
different characteristics in this case
height and it's relevant to how well you
can see the ball game
you know it's it's an it's a level
playing field let's just put them all on
the ground and see who can see through
the fence then there was the idea of
compensating for inequity so the short
person gets a box to stand on okay so
they can see over the fence so that's
better right because now everybody can
see over the fence
however the box is there and everybody
knows it's there so what you really want
is a fence that's transparent that is
that you don't have an accommodation
that needs to be made that you
just make everything accessible and I
think right now we're sort of in the
middle panel in in in the US and we need
to be in the third okay I'm going to end
with my formerly 11 now 12 steps to
success for people in these outsider
groups you'll see why it's 12 maybe at
the end eleven is because of spinal tap
you guys this is spinal tap you haven't
seen it you should see that movie
it's very good you haven't seen it
either and you guys are older no oh my
god okay well eleven is a number they're
just so you know um okay the first thing
is to work hard at something you love if
you don't do good work there's you know
nobody's gonna pat you on the back make
sure it's interesting make sure it's
high impact that as other people are
interested in if you find an uneven
playing field please don't be
discouraged just recognize it's not you
it's this tilt that is pushing you down
you know downhill and you need to you
need to separate this is kind of
directly related to imposter syndrome
you need to separate your feeling of
inadequacy you need to identify its
origin as the tilt not the not the you
know you this is a plea from my heart
please reject the idea of lower
standards a colleague once told me he
said you'll be so happy Meg we have not
been able to find any women to hire as
faculty because they don't meet our high
standards but we're going to lower our
standards so we can hire women
I nearly freaked out as you can imagine
you don't need to lower standards to
hire highly qualified people in fact if
you aren't hiring a divert if you aren't
hiring people as diverse as the relevant
applicant pool you have lowered your
standards
to hire the majority group that's what
that is what is happening at most
institutions today okay
mentor each other you won't always be
able to find mentors people won't always
come up to volunteer to mentor you
find your own mentors and mentor others
even peer mentoring is really important
network with one another if you find
yourself alone like if you're the only
woman in your research group if you're
the only gay person in your department
find others like you in a similar
position maybe in a different department
different universities so that you can
have a place to talk about to talk about
what that's like to relieve stress to
plan strategy ah ok this is my own
personal Bugaboo but I'm just gonna use
your first and last name okay when
you're in the university when you're
here this is a professional space and
your last name is your professional
identity so always introduce yourself as
you know I'm Meg URI and if you have a
difficult name don't smush it together
like I'm Meg you're you know just so
that people it does two things one it's
so people really know your name and two
it establishes you as a professional I
think this is really important for women
in this space particularly because
you're the ones who are likely who are
more likely to be assumed to be in some
subordinate role and when you announce
yourself in a professional way you're
raising your status relative to what
people might have expected from you okay
prepare an elevator speech anybody know
what that is yeah okay a short three
sentences who you are where you're from
what you want whatever something like
that so if you're standing by your
poster maybe it's the three sentences
about what your research was practice
your confidence so I thought you had a
very interesting statistic we say 70% of
us have imposter syndrome but 40% of
highly successful people have imposter
syndrome now is that because people with
imposter syndrome can't be highly
successful no no it's not but it is
because we judge others on their on
their expressed confidence and a lot of
successful people are just people who
know how to
confident so you should practice first
of all ice
I personally think it's so much easier
to remember bad stuffs and good stuff so
I can remember insults and criticisms
from decades ago verbatim but a
compliment I can remember that for about
ten minutes maybe a week if it's a
really good ones so we have to we have
to consciously reverse that so when
you're alone maybe when you're brushing
your teeth at night you're looking in
the mirror why don't you admit to
yourself that you really have done some
great things and just give yourself a
compliment every single night don't make
it up it's all true you just have to
kind of it is not the kind of thing you
are always willing to say publicly so
say it privately and just practice give
great talks everybody can learn how to
give a great talk or at least a decent
one and own your ambition women in
particular are told that ambition is a
bad thing so I think we should all
celebrate being ambitious and we should
aim to achieve our ambitions now I
usually stop there but about three years
ago when I was president of the American
Astronomical Society we had a major
sexual harassment scandal and and I
suddenly started hearing from all kinds
of young women about the problems they'd
had in in the profession and I had no
idea it was so prevalent to be honest so
I want to say watch out for sexual
harassment be be prepared to deal to
deal with it this is a very funny time
to be talking about this but let me not
go on there are many things you can do
but it is it is astonishing and deeply
disturbing
how many talented talented young
scientists have been driven out of their
fields by sexual harassment even by
things as simple as a guy wanting a date
you say no and he ruins your chances to
go on in that field that is so common it
is shockingly
so I want the potential victims of
sexual harassment to be prepared to deal
with it I want everyone to be prepared
to defend the victims of sexual
harassment to stand up for them and to
out the people who are doing this
they're slowly coming in to view the
worst of them but many many more are
being still being protected so that's
why I have 12 steps for outsiders and
I'll stop there thank you anybody
panelists to come up so you guys already
heard from the two professors I just
want the three graduate students to
introduce themselves and maybe give a
little anecdote about how you overcome
your imposter syndrome
Nicole is this on I guess so yeah so hi
everyone my name is Nicholas Americal
and I am a third-year graduate student
in the department of molecular
biophysics and biochemistry and to tell
you a little bit about my background I
did my undergraduate well I left
imported ego up until two years ago and
I come from a very small undergraduate
institution and as a Latina woman and in
biophysics and biochemistry I'm no
stranger to imposter syndrome but more
than imposter syndrome I'm no stranger
to external doubt as well and the
imposter syndrome is something that I'm
still struggling with I try very hard to
acknowledge my accomplishments but I've
found that I've sort of am well I've
gotten better about dealing with
external doubt and a lot of what has
been said today has really resonated
with me and I look forward to hearing
and discussing this very important topic
with all of you because it is very it's
a very predominant feeling not only at
our stages not only at your stages but
at ladder
and higher professional stages as well
so it's great that we're having this
discussion hi my name is Elias Quijano
I'm a fourth year MD PhD student and I
went to Yale undergrad and was also a
first gen college student and you know
one of the things that was talked about
today was sort of how these feelings of
inadequacy can create a lot of anxiety
and I think for me especially in my
first year of college feeling you know
like I was an imposter and also feeling
a sense of things I inadequacies alta
din a lot of anxiety and so I did sort
of the typical thing of hiding in a
corner not talking to anyone not seeking
out help and sort of just you know
really just just kind of failing you
know a lot of my classes initially and
not doing very well I think it's
something that I still deal with today
and something I still think about a lot
but I think you know initially that
sense of being an outsider resulted in a
lot of failure created a lot of anxiety
caused me to work like you know in my
sophomore doing year maybe twice as hard
or three times as hard and became a
perfectionist maybe and I think it's
only now that I'm starting to feel
comfortable with you know who I am and
starting to feel like okay maybe I do
belong here but but it's been a pretty
pretty long road and and some of the
things about anxiety and feeling
inadequate I think really you know
sounded familiar
so yeah hi everyone
Robert Fernandez and I'm a six-year grad
student and the molecular biophysics and
biochemistry department so I come from a
family that are not scientists at all
and I went to a very small school in
your car in New York it's called your
college and over there I they don't
really have any mentors or people of
color however I did have mentors that
were strong women mentors and undergrad
I used to be undocumented for 20 years
luckily I received my green card right
before I started grad school so growing
up with no like origin alene no
scientist in the fam
being undocumented I was lucky that I
had strong female role models
specifically api's and when I got here I
felt more isolated where I didn't really
have there were barely any other like
that annex people in my department I
didn't have any it's like new
environment no role models and I fell
alone and similarly I did bat my first
year of grad school but my second year
something I learned is even if I'm in an
environment where I feel isolated you
have to learn to ask for help so I
learned like and that's something hard
for me at least because if we feel that
we ask for help they might have that
perception that of course they're asking
for help and you have to kind of like
not listen to that and so it's the
second year I did much better
academically I learned how to ask for
help and I learned to find people who
share a similar type of background and
like in a way mentor each other help
each other to talk about these very
difficult issues with each other and
always pass on the mentorship I should
say that all three graduate students are
leaders of my stars program so Elias as
you know is he runs he's a coordinator
for stars one and Nicole and Robert
coordinated stars too so you can see
that you know even with this imposter
syndrome they've succeeded and they are
ready to pass down what they've learned
to you guys you know that's the beauty
of being in a you know program like
stars because people who's gone through
the program you know even though they
have a feeling of you know this imposter
syndrome they know how to overcome it
and they want to share that with you and
that your mentors as well participated
in the stars program and they have also
overcome some of their inadequacies as
well so I want to open up the questions
to you guys to the floor do you please
ask the panel any questions you want
so if your yes
hi I'm Natalia Taylor I'm a sophomore in
branford so I'm currently in a class
where I just feel like I'm not on the
same playing field it's very uneven I
know some of the upperclassmen in that
class have taken labs that have given
them more experience in the topics and I
still am very interested in the material
and I want to stay in the class I don't
want to drop it but what would you
recommend in terms of being okay with
not being on that even playing field and
dealing with the fact that I'm probably
not going to succeed grade wise or in
terms of the professor's view on me or
what would you recommend for me or
anybody so yeah so that's um actually a
pretty common experience I think it in
any class and maybe more so for
first-year students who come from such
wildly different backgrounds you know as
the longer you spend at Yale the more
homogeneous you are in terms of
preparation for things and when you
start maybe not it's not like that at
all so I would say first of all it's
easy for me to say this but I hope you
believe me the grades really don't
matter that much what matters is how
much you learn and like whether you're
prepared for the next class so one thing
you have to do is is ask for help
that is to say go to office hours if
there's tutors if there's a study hall
that kind of thing make sure that you're
getting the extra instruction you might
need because you have less of a
background in it than some of your
classmates but you can also go to the
classmates I mean assuming they're they
should be willing to answer your
questions and help as well sorry there's
one other thought there but maybe I'll
stop so other people can give advice so
I would start out by saying that it's
pretty early on in the semester and that
you don't have to assume that you'll do
badly because you still have so much
time to make up for whatever you've done
so far and I would also encourage you to
seek out the TAS
as a TA myself like it's my job to to
help out students who feel like you do
and put in the extra work and sit down
with them and equal to as as as much as
I can make that playing field a bit more
equal so I definitely encourage you to
reach out to the TAS
hi I'm barn Daniel I'm actually one of
the senior stars mentors but I'm asking
this question wouldn't ask I'm asking it
because I've been here for three years
now and I don't really feel like this
quite I've had gotten answer this
question yet
and there are my first year here first
couple years here people you saw a lot
of times referred to say oh you want to
take class X that's a weed out course
and I'm wondering like how for example
some of us can learn to deal that with
impostor syndrome when we are told that
certain classes are we now courses
because a lot of classes are have been
described as weed out classes telling
you that is that faculty or is that
students it's its students I haven't
heard that directly from a faculty
member it's usually for example when I
would ask an upper-class to Malaya or /
class all soon hey I'm going to take
math 120 and then they would say oh
that's a weed out court for mathematics
or I'm going to take X physics class oh
that can be also weed out class too and
I'm just wondering how exactly someone
would cope with that like with imposter
syndrome after hearing something like
that so
so let me I'm sorry I should let but let
me just say I I don't think there are or
certainly there should not be any weed
out classes for anything here at Yale
they're all meant to be classes for
stuff you need to learn and then the the
notion that that people are saying this
it has a differential impact on the
people they're saying it to and right so
for example in art in our intro physics
we have several different levels it
depends on how much physics you had
before and for years we've had the
problem our sort of honors physics is
too full so in order to discourage
people
from you know just to get the people who
are best prepared the professor says you
know don't come to this class if you
don't have a 5 in ap physics BC and you
don't have you know great grades and
blah blah blah and what happens the
girls walk right out the door and the
boys who are forgive me they're over
continent they stay and so even if what
you're trying to do is be helpful it is
actually really damaging it's very
differentially received I think probably
your you've experienced that so perhaps
you know y'all can pass this along that
as far as I know we don't have any I
mean of course we don't have any weed
out classes and these are classes these
are 4 things you need to learn and we
have to do the strategies like you
mentioned to learn these things I would
add to that and say ask like weed out to
who write because it it's impossible
that all students are perceiving this in
the same way and I would definitely hope
that you don't feel discouraged from
taking those courses because as an
undergraduate there were definitely
those those we out courses in my
institution but I felt like I needed to
do what was best for my career in terms
of the courses that I was taking so
whether or not it was a weed out course
was outweighed for the benefits that the
class would bring to to my knowledge I
would just say that some of my favorite
classes were definitely the ones that
were described to me as weed out courses
like organic chemistry is the typical
one for people who want to go to medical
school people will say that but it was
definitely by far my favorite course was
also of course that I took my junior
year where I really already knew how to
ask for help and knew how to seek tutors
and seek support so I think that also
contributed to how much I was able to
enjoy it was because I actually went to
office hours I actually spoke to my
professor and ask questions and followed
up with my TAS and I was really engaged
with the resources that the course
provided and I think that was something
that perhaps I
wasn't able to do as a first year when
imposter syndrome just gave me an
overwhelming sense of anxiety that I
really couldn't then I wasn't equipped
to deal with so to answer your question
sometimes the you it may seem that it's
very difficult to take that step but
what you may want to do sometimes it
helps is write it out like why exactly
is it difficult and once you actually
take that step you you should know that
you're not like like all of these
courses
requited are difficult or not like
everyone face different challenges
throughout different levels of academia
even all the professors the grad
students no one is like no one's a
genius right off the bat and as long as
you work hard and ask for help and if
anything help each other look for people
who can relate to what you're going
through and help each other succeed I
heard once someone was being interviewed
about some difficult task and they asked
that person or you know they told that
person you know what are you doing this
you know why don't you do something else
and the response was something like I
cannot not do that and still be me and I
think but that what that refers to is
that if there's a reason why you want to
take a class there must be something
inherent in you that it's part of who
you are and your identity and the one
thing that you want to preserve is that
part of you so even though there's the
impostor is gonna cast doubt in things
but there there's that part of you that
you want to protect you know the
integrity of who you are even if the
class means you know I don't know Mount
Everest
but there's but that's do you know don't
don't don't don't let outside things
discourage you from pursuing the things
that you want to learn we have a record
number of first generation of students
in the Stars program I was wondering
whether there's any first gen students I
have any anxieties or questions they may
want to ask the panelists uh hi my name
is Leslie Espinosa um I guess my
question is what are good ways to find
mentors or like good ways of reaching
out to those people who are who are
those people you should reach out to
yeah okay so in terms of finding mentors
it's at times it's something that
happens naturally whether you're taking
a class and you find that you and a
particular professor interact quite well
and sometimes you the more you go to
office hours the more you get to know
the professors and even if there are
other professors that you would like to
get to know better to be a particular
mentor reach out to them there have been
cases where you know undergrads who I
haven't met before reached out to me
about guidance and I was happy to help
them of course but the that's something
I wouldn't have done as undergrad I was
lucky where mentors came to me and said
I think you would be good at research
but you should also take that step and
go out to go to a particular faculty
member that you want to get to know
better and say do you have time to meet
for me for lunch to discuss these things
what's the worst is gonna happen they're
gonna say no then you could find another
better mentor also depend on your needs
because there's different type of
mentoring relationships but most of the
mentoring relationships that I'm in kind
of happened
organically as well and I and I think
that that's been very good
but definitely as Rob mentioned I've
been I've been lucky to find those
mentors or have them find me
quickly things one people love to be
asked for advice if you go to someone
and say I'm thinking about graduate
school what what should I be seeing
about or I'm interested in doing a
summer research project how do I do that
people love to give you advice and I
forgot the second thing so you have to
go oh no sorry it was email roll the to
email roll if you send an email to
professor's thing I want to meet with
you some of us don't even read email
some days and because you know you get
200 and you can't and you don't ever
catch up for months so if you don't hear
back in a few days or a week forward
your original email and say I don't know
if you had a chance to see this give
them a second chance to see it because
on that day they might be reading email
but don't do it 10 times you know but
who is definitely definitely a good idea
okay so when I first came in here I was
psychology division I was the only
Latino and I had really nice mentors in
the system but it didn't look like me
and I couldn't do it in Spanish this is
difficult and it was very hard to find
but what I did is one was I was
apprehensive because I thought people
might not wanna mentor I find out I was
wrong people really were open about it
so I started looking and then I found
people outside now today with you know
all these kind of internet all these
things you could mean sometimes you just
if you don't find internal you can find
people outside try it out and see if it
works and then and then and then that
might lead back to people that they know
inside but sometimes it takes a little
bit of work to do but most of the time
it works nicely
so one of the things we're gonna do for
the stars one student is that we have a
stars Advisory Committee made out of
professors so one thing we're gonna do
is actually we're gonna pair up the
stars you know because when you guys
apply the Stars you guys all listed like
potential interests and majors and
things like that so we're actually gonna
pair up professors who are working in
area so that you may be interested in
with you know you guys and have the
professor's email you guys for meals and
things like that because we know that
you know sometimes the first year
mentoring service doesn't work some of
you are stem majors but may have a
humanities person advise you which it's
not the ideal situation unfortunately so
we would like to have our stars Advisory
Committee to be a little more active and
they all are have agreed to do this so
you expect the email from from them
sometimes if you don't get one of them
you know talk to me other questions hi
my name is Janet Rivera I'm appears 1 oh
sorry oh stars one peer mentor as a
first gen students a lot of times just
getting to yell is a giant
accomplishment for yourself and your
family so once you're at Yale and say
you face your first time dealing with
failure or just social anxiety or
depression it's really hard to then talk
about that with your family who thinks
that you're great just for being at Yale
so how do you suggest going on about
that I think you're definitely not the
only person at Yale going through that
at any stage like I know that like being
I feel the same way about like having my
family think that like I'm this huge
success but like being in a lab comes
with so many frustrations right so I
think creating a network that you're
comfortable with and that really
understands those struggles that has
been at least in my case what has gotten
me through yeah I think one of the
things that was interesting for me as
for
here was it so I went to high school in
Florida in Miami and it particularly in
this place that's known as Hialeah and
it's like very very Hispanic and even
the way you express yourself and carry
yourself was very different and so when
it came to Yale it was really difficult
for me to even express my anxieties or
some of my insecurities in ways that
felt comfortable to me in ways that I
would want to express them just because
of language barriers and cultural
barriers and things like that and so I I
was able to find you know through my
dean of of lacasa dean garcia at the
time and also dr. miranda i was able to
find people who i could sort of relate
to culturally a little bit and and that
to me was a really big service and
really really helpful and sort of
allowed me to express my anxieties in a
way that felt comfortable and natural to
me just based on the way I had grown up
so that's kind of you know one of the
things that helped me a lot as a
first-gen students as you said like you
know and as you say my family thinks I'm
really smart but then yeah I didn't
always feel that way yeah this whole
issue of trying to find resources that
are congruent with your background can
be really helpful what you don't want to
do is be isolated and and and and and
not talk to anyone because then that's
gonna compound on it and then by by
virtue of if you can get resources if
you can talk to someone about it then
you can figure out how to how to
communicate with the family about it you
know if need be
in terms of what's the best way to
approach it you know yeah so to add on
to that sorry one thing that we haven't
really answered is how do you find that
network right this magical network that
we're all mentioning and I think la casa
is a great resource and from lacasa stem
a lot of student organizations both at
the undergraduate and undergraduate and
graduate level and this is kind of a
shameless plug for sickness but I know
SACNAS has like social even though it's
not mrs. Oh sickness is a society that
is for advancing minorities and
their presentation in the sciences and
they have an annual conference and as
well as university chapters and we here
at Yale just established chapter last
year and we do social events as well as
professional development events for both
undergraduates and graduate that are
designed to foster that kind of networks
so and I know that there's other great
organizations here at Yale that also
foster that so I guess we should just
mention a few there's you know for
example in physics which I obviously
know the best there's a women in physics
at the graduate level there's an
undergraduate level there's women in
science at Yale which is across the
sciences there are a lot of these groups
and and I think I think it's really
really important to find a group that
you can relax in you know that you can
ask people tough questions and and and
get answers which you can't always do in
your lab or in your department I'm
hoping that stars can be a group like
that right we you know students who are
coming from similar backgrounds and that
you could mentor each other help each
other in terms of you know mental health
needs I should also mention that you
know the culture houses for this year
for the first time have for example a
casa have spanish-speaking cultural
sites like a psychiatrist and and people
in the mental health arena so they could
talk to for example students I would
frequent like Casa and that there's also
such support for students in the FM
house and the asian-american house and
the Native American houses as well so if
you are you know a frequent if you
frequent these culture houses look for
these support and for the first time
there are these you know we should be
called like cultural sensitive mental
health support that you know no
questions asked you can go and just talk
to people and we we understand that a
lot of first gens or or people from you
know
come into Yale feeling a sense of
detachment right that's what we have
this like process in Japan oh so I think
some of the mental health services
that's cultural house base could be very
useful I want you guys to be aware of
these opportunities hi my name is Andrew
Winn
I'm a first year here at Berkeley first
of all thank you for coming to talk
I just wanted to harp on a dr. Yuri you
brought that experiment with the picture
with the business table and then a
mixture of men and women and people
would pick who they thought was later I
just finished the book blink by Malcolm
Gladwell I just want to get your opinion
all of your guys's I guess I'm more of
like a psychology side so it brings up
the I guess the theory for like tall
CEOs for fortune 500 companies and how I
guess for fortune 500 companies I guess
for over 6 feet tall the CEOs or 30%
you know presidents - actually yeah so
it comes to play I was interested in
like physical attraction being played
into competency and then your height
alone into like your ability to be a
leader you know I don't know if that's
something that's evolutionary or is that
something that's like up for your
societal upbringing is it something that
will be like that all the time
do you think you know your height your
your physical attractions plays into
your ability to lead or what people
think of you and is that is it wrong to
just accept that's just the way it's
gonna be
that's a really good question I think
it's I think it's just learned right I
for example what's the first thing you
learned you're a kid your parents are
tall right
your parents are authorities they have
the answers they have the power so we
all grow up thinking tall people have
power I have no doubt that you know some
of the things that have helped me
succeed in physics is I'm tall I am
white I forgot to mention earlier that's
a big advantage that I'm actually you
know of a man majority group also I have
a low voice for a woman and a low voice
gets you more authority one of
great icons of astronomy Margaret
burbage British woman has a very high
voice and one time she was speaking to a
group of astronomers and someone asked
her why you know why she had a difficult
path and astronomy and she said well
perhaps they couldn't hear my voice you
know I think it really all those things
have an effect and will they forever no
I'm a firm believer that once we changed
the face of science the expectations of
people will be completely different once
we have 50% women who are faculty once
we have 50% once we have a woman
president once we have half the Congress
being female and half the Supreme Court
being female and maybe not all being
Catholic you know once we have more
diversity then people's expectations of
diversity are start to be cooked in it
but it's very slow change it's change
that happens on you know times lifetimes
really the first woman was appointed to
the Supreme Court does anyone remember
when 1981 83 that's great
83 was Sandra Day O'Connor
I always forget if it's 83 because
that's also when Sally Ride became the
first u.s. woman in space although she
was long after decades after the first
Russian woman in space anyway once these
things happen
okay the first one is always the
pioneering thing and that doesn't really
change the culture but once you have
enough it does change the culture and it
changes the expectation in in the
physics department here when I arrived
in 2001 which to you is ancient history
but it's not that long ago I was the
only woman on the faculty I was the
first woman ever tenured in that
department
in 2001 we're taking up the modern era
you know it's craziness and now we have
six women five or ten iord and so the
young women who are majoring in physics
now they actually see lots of potential
futures for themselves but they didn't
see that before and do we have enough
other diversity not really
there's a long way to go but I think it
will happen and it and and it will
happen if if people who who want to do
those things don't give up just because
it's harder it is harder I mean that's
the vaccination I'm sorry it's a little
harder for people who aren't who don't
look like the dominant group but if you
stick it out you will be able to change
it for the people coming behind you I
think that's really important by the way
most CEOs are psychopaths do you know
that like on the Psychopaths index
anyway in some in some countries in
Latin America if it's a person is too
tall then a CEO they it won't work no
this time yes it looks out of context
and they'll they'll make jokes about
that person that that that we have run
into from time to time the whole thing
about Thor is very interesting because
if when you're looking at from the early
you know if you look I'm back in the
armies and the people in charge of the
army would be on a horse and the rest of
them are walking and then you had these
plates right think of you know this
whole kind of persona that was created
and I think it's you're so now now as
you not the kid grows up now we're all
adults I gotta be taller than you so
I'll get on a horse the kind of stuff
but a height a qualities depend on the
context depends of the culture of the
place as well so learned I don't think
it's evolutionary at all there may be
big advantages to being close the ground
you know well if you look at it if
you're looking from an evolutionary
point of view and if you look in there
so it takes almost a pians right but if
you took I took at the animal kingdom
smaller is better
you know nuclear holocaust that Raj you
saw this morning it'll be in it won't be
the Planet of the Apes is gonna be the
planner of the roach
but but and but if you look at small
animals will survive I mean historically
when there's been extinctions smaller
was better yeah interesting
okay there's no other questions let's
thank our panelists
[Applause]
[Music]